こんにちははじめした超です皆さん秋といえば
芸術結局辿り着くな芸術なんです芸術 f つくしーものはすべての二頭身美塩する
そんな素晴らしい技術書をみなさまと楽しみたいために私こんな企画を準備しました
ディナー見てる皆さんそう
youtube を見ている今そこにいる皆さん君たちが3箇所です
第1回
10分を発揮
[音楽]
han ga 社長
たいがーい
バッハ
yeah
まあ劣化入ったわけで前回ですねあの僕の動画を使って何か
動画編集してくださいって私と企画だったんですけどそれがすごい好評であった
めちゃくちゃ面白かったんですよね
負ければ動画編集って言ってやっハードルが上がっちゃってなかなかねその
youtube 見てですの坊やとか見てると思うんですけども防衛だとナッパ動画
弊社難しいなと思ったんで今回は意外と誰でも参加できるようにですね
イラストイラストというか子美術書いたりなんかにユーロして画像
皆さんで作ってもらえないでしょうかという感じの今ですになっておりますそんなに
初めて署名を格納って思われると思うんですけどもそういうわけではなく僕が今から1
枚の写真を皆さんにお配りいたしますあぁでも悪用しないで下さいねあくまでこの度
となるために皆さんに配っているのでこの動画のコンテスト以外は使わないでください
で僕の1枚の写真を開かれ皆さんに配りますのでその画像を使って1枚の写真を作って
いただけるととても嬉しいでございますで皆さんにお配りてる画像がこちらになります
はいはーー座ってますねどけどなかなかモナリザ的な何かを感じますがこの
写真をぜひみなさん加工なりなんなりして1枚の画像を作ってください
ただ必ずこの画像を使ってイラストどっか画像とかでを変えたりするっていう感じ
皆さん今なぜにしっかりとスクショとかダウンロードがおっしゃってください
実は僕のツイッター島を挙げておくのでそちらからダウンロード保存して頂いても結構
でございます排気指でちょっと皆さんに求められるのは僕がに浦和へとかイラストとか
じゃなくてですね
なんかも塗り絵みたいな感覚ですねこの画像のここだけは残していてこの周りでナント
カスってくださいみたいな
イメージだと思っていただいて結構でございますまんなーに僕だけ置いてあるっていう
設定だけで後は何でも j にしちゃって ok ですからこの事は塗りつぶさは何を
しても結構なのであの皆さんの思い描く
芸術的なはじめ札を作っていただけるドアの僕とでも楽しみにしておりますよろしくお
願い致します例えばでちょっといろいろ考えています例えばこういう画像です古い
に中村とが集落みたいな画像があるからこれだけのちょっと
若干技術っぽく見えるのではないでしょうかまあこういう理由はがないところに置いて
あっても ok ですねが回るに人とかおいでも良いですしてもう何しても結構なので
もう塗り絵みたいな感覚ですぬ例みたいなのはなんかいい感じのオサレな画像見れたら
僕はとても嬉しいですあいうえでここからちょっと
応募方法第ルール説明しようと思います横暴方は twitter につぶやくだけで
結構でございます画像をつけてつぶやいていただくんですけどもその時にハッシュタグ
始め秋のイラスト武道会始め秋なイラスト舞踏会っていうハッシュタグのタグだけつけ
てくれれば私が全部チェックしますのでぜひ皆さんツイッターに投稿してくださいね
よかったなっても行っちゃったらどんなこと発表会動画で発表しますのでその方の
ツイッターとかが出ちゃったりするんでそこだけはご了承下さいませ後はそうですよ
使っちゃダメの画像とがいろいろも黒いのも他の人が写ってたりとかそういうなんか
著作権的に良くないのも全部止めてくださいあのイラストとかもそうです限りすべての
権利が大きいのやつあげ使ってください
書いたりしてそこに僕だけペタッと貼るとかでも全然いいと思うんで
もうなんかこういうパソコンとが ipad とかで書いてもいいし僕のだとだけ
切り取って園にベタって貼ってもいいと思いますのでの素敵な芸術作品を是非お待ちし
ておりますで期間なんですけども11月1日の0時までお待ちしております10月中
募集って感じです多分発表や11が
普通にしますのでぜひ皆さんの素敵なはず女殺王のい傘をお待ちしております山路なん
かこういうぼくだけ本で座ってる奴って結構過去しがいがあると思うんですよ
あのどうにでも好きにいじってくださいスティたと思った作品どんどん紹介させて
いただきます
じゃあ皆さん発表会でお会いしましょう the な
[音楽]
me
バッハ